things change some script revisions had
to happen in order to logistical II
actually complete our shoot but in the
end we're finishing we got it done we're
gonna hang out tonight and head back
home tomorrow do we have everything we
need to tell a good story absolutely do
we have everything we need to make a
good quarter video absolutely do we have
everything we need that the brand wants
I'm pretty sure we're close we're not
using octane welcome to another episode
of the actor the actors process they've
brought me this new high tech back
healing device and taught me this method
this advanced method
thank you I'm just writing down the
stuff we got to get shootin pickups
today there's a couple things in the
Edit where we've messed up the line when
we were shooting it oh my god Gabe are
you rotoscope big blades of grass the
idea is that you're like you're so
focused on just hurting these guys you
never thought for a second that anyone
could touch what's so close to you but
it happened and you don't quite believe
it
I'm gonna grab that ladder for my
blast-off in this same tape action
oh so good ended a Monday you guys
deliver that Monday through Wednesday
we're gonna get clientís okay
Wednesday we're gonna give you the final
cut which is final cut final the effects
final music for you and and some notes
from client - to address by end of day
Thursday with the final mix down yeah
that's the situation we got this
check out this affectionate green is
done final ready to upload red means
there's notes blue means it's being
worked on white untouched
most of the stuff that's green is like
is difficult a lot of the red is almost
there and it's difficult the white is
actually white pretty easy Blue is like
intermediate at this point but most of
the difficult stuff is out of the way we
have two days to finish these effects
two days to implement all the client
notes and then we OH final cut with
client notes final VFX final music -
Eric who's doing all the sound by end of
day Wednesday
you might want to intercut this with me
describing it schedule you know I have
to take this thing home tonight well
this is yours yes really is my okay well
so I'm just gonna start erasing this
right now wait I think it's just gonna
use this this line no it's in Google
those are friendships Sam you took all
the lines and smushed them into lime
juice with your feet I know I saw those
green toes I do know one thing or
another every shot that needs to be
rendered out of cinema4d
for this phone for tonight video cued
ups all I have to do is go home in 12
minutes and hit render by the time I get
back I expect it to still be rendering
that means a lot of work has been done
Wallace
I felt so fulfilled creatively using
cinema 4d I can do anything do anything
if I learn how to do it this is a place
where I can practice my different
creative skills and grow them cinema 4d
is one of those skills and it unlocks
whole nother level of storytelling you
can do anything you do absolutely
anything and right now I'm building a
massive fort made of pool noodles no
joke I wouldn't been able to do this
shot if I didn't just like look up
tutorials mostly from greyscale gorilla
Manor we got that daylight setup going
on
we got HDRI studio rig going on man they
just make it so easy I don't know Amy
you just got something to really want
this I'm up in the Chocolate Factory
right now but the Chocolate Factory is
grace go gorilla and cinema4d you didn't
take a deep dive in the chocolate River
I I have I've been diving I'm in that
chocolate over right now
I'm coming out the other end with a lot
of chocolate working on the tons of roto
have leftovers we have all these
wonderful bunny pool effects in this
piece we forgot about all the stuff that
goes in front of these effects it's a
lot of work explosion shining down there
oh good I'm ready to talk about whatever
man uh I have to come in and afterwards
I'm down to do that yeah let's do that
cuz it sounds like people they want to
know some of the effects in that whole
way down until I do it late this week or
mid next week okay yeah do you think
moons country yeah yeah sure who's it
worked in the Clinton it's great I love
working it's very very chill low stress
he's very clear in his directions which
is it's kind of hard to find for most
people who are directing these pieces
applause well actually really bossy
super demanding it's got a Chinese you
can finish the shops oh no just working
on it dude I'm really gonna need you to
finish that stuff dude okay sure okay
seriously I mean there you go like I
said being being super clear with
exactly what you want from a shot like
when it comes to be effects because a
lot of times but I'm working with say
like a studio or something like that
like on these bigger projects I got like
he be short movie I hate to say it
sometimes these people are kind of
expecting you to find out what they want
so like you just go through iteration of
iteration to effects you know they pay a
lot of money for these effects so they
really want to like get their money's
worth but yeah it's hard to find someone
who's gonna be like oh yeah that's it
that's exactly what I want all right
that's not what I want and this is
exactly what it is and you're doing like
maybe to to like five generations
instead of like fifty to like 75 yeah
usually when that happens you get to the
southern good one and they're like you
know I like the second iteration you did
let's go back to that and just tweak it
a little bit John's best feature he's
dedicated to the job that's the first
thing he's here later than myself and
it's nice because that sometimes people
are like trying to get out as fast as
possible and leave early and stuff but
John actually stays late and gets the
work done
that's like first diplomas and the work
he does is quality those are like two
things that should seem like a given but
they're not always a given in this case
like it's it's so helpful because we
have a lot of shots put a lot of
difficult shots John I'd say is an
advanced VFX artist and he's down to do
stuff that you know like rotoscoping you
know John is is well-versed in 3d and
that stuff is so much fun
asking John's rotoscope I would say it's
kind of like a misdirection of skill
because if he's the only one who can do
like advanced stuff and like give him
all the advanced stuff right but in this
case there's so much to do that everyone
has to pick up their weight and everyone
has to work as hard as they can and he's
down to do that stuff he doesn't claim
that that's crucial soggy corn quit
Cassavetes idea
Pop's Corn Pops are the best cereal
they're like yellow things yeah yeah
little yellow puff ball yeah I don't use
a lot of cops Oh Gino darts it's the
best it's the best cereal across the
plates problem overrated might as well
just pour yourself some oatmeal and
sugar
I'm down for oatmeal hold on the sugar
though but you're right you're right
you're right you're right
honestly though these days my favorite
breakfast is yogurt with almonds and
like some opinion mmm that's that's
pretty good
ooh some stuff is rendered I'd say more
than half of the stuff is rendered and
ready for you to jump in like you're
doing now
yeah the other book was being rendered
currently what about the shots were we
running along the trail on the wall the
foam walls are popping out that was the
render that took honor 20 it was taking
her 27 hours yeah wait really it's
because it's lip service Karen what I
think I mean it took 15 hours to render
five frames I know I know it's bad I'm
redoing that I'm gonna have Gabe do roto
on that once it's ready that'll be one
for you to come yeah okay as well and
there's also the shot where we come
walking up to the chest that's a gig
roto you comp situation that hasn't been
rendered it's cued up now same for 1:10
the one of the wooden wall getting
destroyed uh-huh same situation I'm
still working on all that I'm finishing
up the storm shots we storm father how
do their storm shots going epically dude
we need to get like storm father instead
of friend it's a stray storm bother with
a lightning bolt instead of it look
quarter Logan that's that's pretty much
the bulk of your stuff yeah sure sounds
good I think this is very doable we
should be able to be able to finish this
by early next week tomorrow night
tomorrow mid-day yeah now we should be
done by tomorrow should be hopefully
hopefully we can get all this done by
tomorrow
midday we lose John after today so good
riddance you've worked with rent a lot
right I have obviously great things
about working around if you want to
figure out the fastest way to get to
work done or probably the most efficient
way Renne the guy to talk to 90 and 95
percent of the time when working on
these shots the hardest part is figuring
out where to begin there's gonna be a 3d
shot or it's gonna be 2d shot and if
it's gonna be to be how am I gonna do it
this like the right way you usually just
ask him and he'll have some crazy way to
like do it quickly like how would I get
how would I pull a key from this shot
that doesn't have a green screen or
anything like that and he'll like oh
just invert it make a mask out of it and
so on so forth and we'll just get it
done so that's definitely the best part
of working with Brent do you like
working with Brent no I hate him he's
the worst
not me no I actually work on the rent
rate why we get stuff done so fast is
because he's usually the one who's like
assigning the shots and how to do them
[Music]
team render working on cinema 4d and
it's the best oh my god it saved me so
much time I came to the office today and
found that a render was gonna take me
104 hours and that's not acceptable
because the videos do this Saturday it's
currently Wednesday midday that shot
that was taking like 15 hours per frame
shouldn't take more than 5 seconds per
frame in Achtung
[Music]
yeah and that would literally take
seconds to render an octane I not render
it all on Ren's computer which has
oxygenated it's it's it's not nearly as
it's like yeah different lighting system
different material system you have to
kind of start from the beginning so I
got team render working which means I
have this computer games computer events
computer Sam's computer and Nico's
computer all just using up their their
computer juice to help me render that's
what I have going on on that computer
it's rendering now yeah Ren he is
working on compositing all the stuff
that has been rendered into the
live-action footage we got Gabe just
busting out some roto and then I'm
rendering other stuff other things out
of cinema 4d on this computer like darts
flying in so it's just render city today
I have to send final cut to to sound
with final notes and then they have a
version due back tomorrow then we have
to send the client a virgin tomorrow
mid-day virgin a virgin we had sent a
virgin to client tomorrow mid-day so
that Jay can hop on the phone with them
and make sure everything is all good
about comic stuff so he made a render he
picked out this render it's tracked into
the shots
Gabe rotoscoped Nico and I running in
the problem is that the render isn't
composited yet and that's that's a whole
big step there's an entire industry
revolving around compositing so envy
effects when you make a render like this
great you have a thing but now it's time
to actually put it in your scene in for
instance in this scene I have to put it
inside the grass it's mean grated no it
means using these elements like these
that have transparency to them and I'm
going to make that as an alpha mat a
track mat for the render so that it
looks like it's sitting in the grass
this the shape of grass cut out of it
but we're not actually gonna the intent
isn't to see this grass so I'm gonna put
it right above our layer here I'm gonna
set our wall to just set it to alpha
inverted Matt look at that so the grass
is gone boom it's just literally a
cookie cutter cut out into the render of
the walls let's make it look like it's
sitting in the grass this is Matt hard
Jake on a phone call with the client
they have a lot of concerns a pretty
intense conversation right now about
that it's one of the main ones they have
a couple other notes I'm rendering out
the final cut close to very close time
they could pull the video possibly and
be like we're not posting or something I
don't know
I'd be worst case scenario
it's kind of like 5050 at this point I
do appreciate the references that you
guys have sent us we're emphasizing his
dominance of the battlefield and that's
when you can go into the close-ups of
the blaster working because you're
emphasizing he's just dominating the
battlefield he's dropping fire on us we
can make that work in the Edit and that
addresses what you guys are looking for
mm-hmm thank you
so I think it's possible to film stuff
at it I'm going to try and not do any
edit changes I there's a spot for the
sniper instead of a second shot of you
just shooting more it'll just be a solid
shot of the sniper when we send it to
him we also need to send them the cut
down and the Youtube upload that as in
like here's what we would go live with I
totally get what you're coming from it I
feel like we can address what they're
looking for here every 124 - yeah you're
right okay let's go
hey guys I'm Niko the initial shot of
him shooting where the chemicals mm
start shooting then it cuts the chase
music and then the stuff we're shooting
is gonna be the following shots where
it's like sweet shots of the gun right
fire yeah no I got you
so what is the most interesting thing
about this gun I guess is the magazine
yeah
as it's being fired
maybe play
inside them
real close up on that or something
it would be as if I'm standing
yeah Rand maybe maybe those tickets okay
yes and I'm just trying to get this out
so I can go to lunch hungry
all those shots those extra shots make
the video way better
[Music]
what about it well I mean it's like if
look if you're in to like nerf guns or
foam blast their guns whatever you want
to call it if you're into that like you
know if you're into the technical
aspects of it you know you're in but
you're technically mechanically minded
person is some some regard so showing
showing off how they work and what
school